il est 10 heures dans la cuisine du
collège mozart de bois d'arcy cathy
gastrin chef de cuisine prépare un
beurre blanc une sauce pour accompagner
le dos de cabillaud ou la côte de veau
avec des pommes de terre le menu destiné
aux 600 élèves de l'établissement une
réduction de vin blanc avec de riches a
lot ensuite qu'on monte au beurre avec
du beurre bref c'est pour accompagner le
poisson quitte à un vieux camion
aujourd'hui avec des pommes de terre à
la vapeur pour mon travail avec le
conseil départemental sur une plateforme
ils ont choisi nos produits là entre
autres c'est du surgelé passe quand une
collectivité en grosse quantité surgelés
plus sur le fret les cuisines ont au
maximum parce que c'est ce qui va faire
baisser une autre cour par le fait des
peluches et des carottes le matin et de
déraper sur place ça nous arrive de
faire des salades des deux lentilles au
lieu de faire une vinaigrette normal
base de moutarde
bah on va faire une vinaigrette à base
d'huile de noisette et de vinaigre de
pomme cuisinés sur place avec des
produits livrés tous les deux jours
cette personne travaille aux côtés de la
chef de cuisine pour l'aider notamment à
recevoir les livraisons il ya de la
civette des tomates de la menthe fraîche
et du persil parce que l'on a prévu au
menu un taboulé libanais les yvelines
consacre 40 6 millions d'euros pour la
restauration scolaire avec des modes de
fonctionnement différent entre les 116
cantines des collèges d'illinois
aujourd'hui le département souhaite
harmoniser sa gestion avec la création
d'une société d'économie mixte à
opération unique les deux tiers du
capital de cette société seront détenus
par l'entreprise qui va avoir la
responsabilité de la fabrication mais
elle ne sera pas délégataire comme on le
fait aujourd'hui c'est à dire elle
décide de tout tout seul
nous serons actionnaires minoritaires
donc le département en tant
qu'institution présidera le conseil
d'admistration ena surveillera cette
société pour s'assurer que la qualité
l'écoutent tout soit bien cadré est bien
conforme au cahier des charges
plusieurs garanties comme l'utilisation
de 20 % de produits bio le respect de la
saisonnalité ou encore le suivi de la
traçabilité des denrées
la réforme sera mise en oeuvre au 1er
janvier 2019